hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime out pro and in this video i will
be discussing the latest
heartbreaking events in the boku no hero
story
with the epic war arc seemingly coming
to a close
we just learned that at least 19 heroes
have lost their lives over the course of
the war
and while most of these heroes were not
well known to us
one of these heroes was an important
character and close to our hearts
so this truly is a tragic moment
in the story this might be the single
most
impactful death on the hero side since
the boku no hero story began
and this death is sure to change the
world of boku no hero forever
but that's not all there is more bad
news for the heroes
shigaraki dobby spinner and presumably
skeptic have
all escaped successfully and all for one
seems to be planning a massive tartarus
prison break
in the near future there is so much to
talk about so
let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like and comment
it really does help and if you're new to
anime outpour or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications according to youtube
statistics
more than half of you guys who watch our
channel are not actually subscribed i
get people telling me that they forgot
to subscribe
all the time and that's why they end up
missing a bunch of our videos so please
if you do enjoy our content
definitely subscribe and hit that
notification bell
finally this video will of course
contain boku do hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the story takes us
back to the
absolutely horrifying aftermath of the
big battle
in jakku city it is quickly revealed
that pixie bob
did indeed survive shigaraki's massive
decay wave from earlier on
in the arc the same goes for present
mike our boy washu
and space hero 13. initially when we saw
pixie bob and the other pussycats facing
down shigaraki's decay
we weren't sure if they actually
survived because we never got to see
what happened to them
since pixie bob survived we could assume
that tiger and mandalay
did as well and i think it's a pretty
safe guess that pixie bob's
earth-bending quirk
is what saved them she was able to
disrupt shigaraki's wave of decay
by throwing a bunch of earth in its path
we know that shigeraki's quirk doesn't
work on substances which are not
solid such as sand so we can assume that
the same applies to earth and dust
i'm actually kind of surprised that
washu survived because he was shown to
be very close to the hospital when
shigaraki's decay began to spread
so personally i thought that he might
have died however
he is in fact okay possibly thanks to
his bubble quirk
we are not yet sure how this quirk works
but perhaps since it is liquid-based it
also has some properties that can negate
the effects of shigaraki's decay
in another panel we get to see our first
glimpse of space hero 13's
face we see an eye and some hair through
a big crack
in her space helmet i remember back when
13 was first introduced
fans speculated whether 13 had a body at
all
and there was also a debate about 13's
gender
some said 13 was male others that she
was female
and others still thought that 13 may not
have a gender in the traditional sense
at all
because she might just be a sentient
black hole it was only much later that
13's gender was confirmed as female
in the my hero academia official
character book 2 which came out in 2019.
we then learned that all the heroes who
were still alive and able to move
inside the city of jakku tried their
best to stop shigaraki from escaping
but the so-called near-high-end nomu
managed to help shigaraki escape
by beating back the heroes and creating
diversions that the heroes simply could
not overcome
fast enough some of the nomu were taken
out but most of them survived and they
were able to get away with shigaraki
dobby spinner and like i said presumably
skeptic
that said gigantomachia and mr compress
who both
still appear to be alive have been
captured by the police
and are being detained compress is also
getting medical help
so perhaps he will actually survive this
one he seemed to believe that he was
definitely going to die
but maybe he'll actually pull through
and if he does he'll definitely be a
valuable source of intel for the heroes
if they can get him to talk back at the
villain mansion
redestro getting and trumpet were
arrested
as well reid destro appears to have been
defeated by headshot
while getting seems to have fought
cementos to a draw since both of them
looked to be out cold
after their battle and these arrests
were only the beginning
apparently nearly 17 000 members of the
paranormal liberation front were
detained
across japan which is a huge number and
you better believe that this will derail
the paranormal liberation front's plans
for the foreseeable future
but that said some 132 known members of
the paranormal liberation front
managed to evade capture and this
includes important
executives of the organization so the
paranormal liberation front has
definitely been crippled by the heroes
and the authorities
for the time being but they may not be
completely defeated
especially if those important members
who are still on the loose are able to
regroup
at some point in the future himiko toga
also
hasn't been captured so she is still out
there somewhere
as i mentioned multiple times in
previous videos i am legitimately
surprised that she didn't do more
during this arc and i am absolutely
surprised that she didn't use her
awakened quirk again
in some major capacity but to be fair
this whole thing may not be over yet
later on in the chapter
all for one hint at the possibility that
yet another major battle is about to
take place in
tartarus prison but i'll talk about that
in a little bit
the rest of the chapter focuses on
giving us a really good sense of how
much destruction and suffering this war
arc has caused for the people of japan
we see innocent civilians crying out in
pain and searching for their loved ones
amidst the rubble and destruction of
jakku
ochako and suyu are able to rescue a
little boy and a girl
after the boy became trapped under the
rubble and the girl who is his sister
tried to save him they were both almost
crushed to death by more falling rubble
before ochako and tsuyu
intervened ochako then comes across a
seriously injured man who is desperately
searching for his wife
and thankfully she manages to locate the
wife and reunite the couple ochoko is
desperate to save as many people as
possible and so are the other heroes
but the scene is absolute chaos there is
so much destruction
so much pain and so much suffering this
scene feels a lot like the aftermath of
a real-life war zone or maybe the
aftermath of some terrible natural
disaster
in real life and for that reason all of
this suffering and chaos felt
so real it is both tragic and scary
on a very human level ochako even sees
one of the other heroes
just standing aimlessly in the midst of
all the carnage
as dozens of people are crying out for
help he simply stands there
bewildered it seems that he cannot
handle the pressure and the gravity
of this situation and he says to himself
that maybe he should find
a new job this might seem like very
unprofessional behavior for a hero to be
exhibiting
but this felt real trauma stress
death devastation all of these dark and
disturbing things are
part of being a hero or for that matter
a first responder of any kind
the hero profession is often glamorized
in the world of boku no hero
you can become rich and famous by being
a hero everyone will love you and praise
you if you're a hero
and so on but this is just one side of
being a hero
there is another far more dark and
tragic side
and not everyone can handle it not
everyone can take
that pressure and sometimes people just
break down
like this hero seems to have done and
in that moment of trauma and chaos
the chapter reveals perhaps the most
tragic death yet
in boku no hero midnight has
died she is among at least 19 heroes who
are shown to have died
during the war arc along with crust and
x-less
both of whom we saw die but there is
also majestic
native that guy who showed up briefly
during the stain arc and was almost
killed by stain
and also that hero who was killed by
twice in the last moments of twice his
life
on top of that at least one of the
heroes that toga slashed back at the
villain mansion while she was disguised
as the hero whom twice had killed is
also on the list it seems that toga
really did
kill him and there are many others
although admittedly those guys were not
well known to us by far the most
well-known hero to die is of course
our girl midnight not only was she a pro
hero
but she was also one of the teachers at
ua and she has been with us since the
beginning of the story
namuri kayama also known as the r rated
hero midnight
was only 32 years old and she was
definitely popular with her students and
with many boku no hero fans
this could be the most significant death
in the entire series so far
at least on the hero side as i said
midnight has been with us
since the beginning the ua students know
her well since she is one of their
teachers
and this death will be just so
heartbreaking for so many heroes
and hero students and of course for many
of us fans
as well previous hero deaths like the
death of sir knight i were definitely
tragic
but we had only met sir nighteye in that
same arc
we didn't know him for a long time and
he certainly wasn't
a ua teacher but i feel like midnight's
death hits
even harder than that we see mina
kirishima
momo and other students weeping over
midnight's dead body as the chapter
reveals that the real cause of all of
these deaths
was shigaraki's immense animosity
apparently his body had died back when
his tube was destroyed
and the electric shock that uchiko
applied wasn't enough on its own
to resuscitate him what really
resuscitated shigaraki were his own
animosity and his own tenacity and that
also makes me think that shigaraki
will resist all for one's possession
but more on that later man it is hard to
believe that midnight
is really gone i don't know if horikoshi
plans to do some sort of
left field bait and switch with this
midnight reveal but from what we've seen
so far
it really doesn't look like it it really
does seem that midnight
has died now let's be honest here we all
knew that some heroes would die
during this battle and some civilians as
well there was just no way that everyone
would survive
this kind of destruction created by
shigaraki gigantomachia
and the other villains and i have been
saying for some time that i think
someone close to deku would die
and that this tragedy would subsequently
change deku
and turn him into a much darker
character but with that
said i didn't think that horikoshi would
kill off a top tier
waifu like midnight seriously i thought
that maybe gran torino would die
because he is already getting on in
years and fighting all for one has kind
of been his life's
mission so it would make sense for
someone like him to make the ultimate
sacrifice
during this battle and since gran torino
was one of deku's most important mentors
his death would definitely lead to some
serious character development for deku
so far it seems that gran torino is
alive just really badly injured
and i did not think that someone like
midnight would be the one to die
she was young popular and she was
someone who always provided both
epic fan service and hilarious comic
relief
i can't help but think back to that
final exam battle between her
and cerro and minota that was a great
moment in terms of developing the
characters of both midnight and
minata and hey cerro was there too
sleeping in midnight's lap like a baby
my boy sarah was the true mvp of that
one
honestly though it's hard to know what
to say at a time like this
midnight will be dearly missed and her
death along with everything else that's
been happening
is going to change every student at ua
and it is going to change the wider hero
society as well
the very next thing that we see in this
powerful chapter
is random people on the street looking
at the news and talking about endeavor
dobby's propaganda campaign is already
working the people are grumbling about
endeavour
always being kind of shady and about the
fact that he has the number one pro hero
clearly failed to protect japan from
this historic
villain attack clearly endeavor doesn't
have what it takes to be the symbol of
peace like
all might was and without a clear symbol
of peace
the hero society might not have that
all-important social glue
that keeps the whole thing together
confidence in the heroes is shattered
and confidence in the number one pro
hero is especially low
after dobby's revelations and i mean
this makes sense
imagine if your own neighborhood was
constantly falling victim to criminal
activity
and then one day entire houses in your
neighborhood were demolished
by insane criminals even if your own
house is fine
you would probably lose faith in the
police clearly they are either unwilling
or unable to protect you
and that is exactly what is happening
with the hero society now
the chapter ends with a shot of all for
one and tartarus
on that very same night dobby spinner
and shigaraki are shown inside a forest
safe
and away from the heroes but it seems
that all for one is still in control of
shigaraki's body
all for one proclaims that it is still
his
turn and he orders the nomu to go free
his main body
from tartarus prison and that is how
this
absolutely insane rollercoaster ride of
a chapter
ends not only has the hero society been
changed forever by this villain assault
not only are many heroes dead and
presumably many civilians as well
not only is there widespread devastation
in multiple cities across japan
but apparently the threat isn't over yet
all for one is planning a prison break
i've been making videos talking about a
potential tartarus prison break for
years here on the channel
and especially after kurogiri ended up
in tartarus i thought that that would
for sure
lead to all for one attempting to escape
after all
kurogiri has the perfect escape quirk so
if the nomu really do break into
tartarus they don't even have to take
all for one out
physically all they would really have to
do is free kurogiri and then kurogiri
could do the rest with his quirk
i'm not sure whether this prison break
is about to happen soon like during this
arc
or if it's going to happen as part of a
future arc but it definitely seems to be
the way that the story is heading
all for one seems determined to take
over shigeraki's body
and use it as his new vessel and if he
can escape from tartarus
and potentially help a bunch of other
top tier villains escape as well
the heroes will be in massive trouble
and if we think about it logically
now is the perfect time to attempt an
escape
the vast majority of the heroes are
currently out on assignment and they are
currently dealing with the aftermath of
the war
if there was ever a time that the heroes
would be too busy and too distracted to
protect tartarus
this is it the heroes might have even
reduced the security at tartarus so that
they can have as many heroes as possible
joining in on the two raids and if this
is the case
if they temporarily lowered the security
then the heroes may come to regret
that decision very soon we'll have to
wait and see but
personally i was very impressed with
this chapter
i'm obviously heartbroken about midnight
she left us far
too soon but at the same time i thought
that this chapter had some truly
incredible moments
we really got to see the extent of the
destruction
and we got to see the consequences that
the war arc has had on the people of
japan
we saw so many civilians suffering we
saw one hero completely breaking down
unable to handle the pressure in the
trauma of such a horrific crime scene
and we saw class 1a students bawling
their eyes out
after discovering the tragic death of
one of their teachers
we also saw that the regular people of
japan are terrified by what
just took place and they are losing
their faith in the hero system and in
the number one pro hero in particular
in a time of such severe crisis that is
not
a good sign this could prove to be
devastating for the hero society as a
whole
in the very near future and finally
we saw that all for one still believes
that this is
his time he has no intention of handing
things off to shigaraki
anytime soon and he is determined to
free his own real body from tartarus
wow just incredible and absolutely
game changing let me know what you guys
think how do you feel about the apparent
death of midnight did any of you see
this
coming also what do you think is going
to happen to the hero society now
is it all about to come crashing down
finally
do you think that all for one is really
about to break out of tartarus
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more pokemon
your content right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar a big
thank you to all of our anime outpour
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
acquired respect liam thompson pate
heffa ruthie and yx
phoenix anime emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life chanel
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers on hell cruise anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokamian water the red-haired raven
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games manwa freaks
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar gives you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you